devin larritt you son of a that's
freaking
what's the matter
mit got you pushing too many pencils all
right you got me
if i wanted to beat you what would i do
here if i can
make you come to me
this is the first step
always make me come to you
exactly it lets you use more muscles
against less muscles you target weakness
right you target my fingertips you get
to use more muscles so you see this
ridge
yeah
very important
the higher up this ridge is in my hand
the better
the more the pressure is in my fingers
as opposed to your fingers the better
right
yeah
wow the strongest arm i've ever felt in
my life
he's not even trying i'm very
specialized i'm a super specialized
athlete ladies and gentlemen devin
lehrer this is a huge honor
you